is a he has a phd from edcs at mit he's
currently a postdoc at uh amazon yes
and he'll be starting assistant
professor at columbia uh in the iur
department student
he's an expert in causal inference i'm
accountable fractured decision making
with observational data and today he's
going to be talking about
some key issues with matrix completion
and the entries are um
hi everyone
thank you very much for the organizers
for inviting me it's a pleasure to be
back here
so today i'll be talking about causal
matrix completion at the end of the talk
uh time permitting i'll talk about some
of its applications to
causal offline rl
um this the first part of the work is
joint work with uh munzer devrath and
dennis munson there were some advisors
at mit along with uh
and uh
dennis is a long time friend
collaborator and he's here at uc
berkeley as a fought c postdoc
so i think matrix completion is probably
very familiar to a lot of you um the
canonical application is uh when we
think of recommendation systems so rows
are different users columns of different
movies
lots more movies than any human could uh
rate and so you see a very sparse
setting a set of entries being observed
and the goal is to somehow recover the
missing entries at the highest level
that's what matrix completion is about
and
when we think about these kinds of
applications of matrix completion to
recommendation systems
uh the data is kind of interesting
looking like what do you observe and
don't observe so if you look at these
are two canonical data sets that people
think about in matrix completion one is
the code data set and another is movie
lens you can see that there's a sort of
clustering that happens within the data
itself certain users tend to rate the
same kind of movies and then they don't
tend to rate anything else right so
people say who like uh horror films
might only watch horror films and
nothing else and people like action
films only watch action forms things
like that so you have this kind of
blocks possibly show up in your in your
data
right so this kind of blocks fast
structure tends to be quite ubiquitous
in in recommendation systems
another thing that people maybe don't
are not so familiar with in in cs and or
is um but is quite familiar in economics
and policy evaluation is
uh things like staggered adoption right
where say rows are different individuals
columns of time and people are adopting
a policy um
in a staggered way say with medicare
um
people adopt medicare at say age 65 or
whatever it is and before that you're
observing the outcomes without medicare
and then you would like to know what
would the outcomes be without medicare
after 65 and that's missing right so
um that kind of leads to this kind of
staircase structure in your data it also
shows up in another kind of design
experiment design that's quite popular
in economics of pilot studies where you
give
an intervention to a small number of
people you see how well it does and
based on that you decide whether to give
it more broadly or to some other
sequence of people so that kind of leads
like a staggered adoption style a
staircase style password with their data
probably one that's very familiar to a
lot of you here probably more than for
me itself is say contextual bandits
yeah say you can think of in the finite
state in action case at least i can
think of rows as states columns as
actions and then each entry would say be
the observed reward for a a particular
state in action tuple
right and then if you're not observing
if you haven't particularly visited that
state action
pupil then that that reward is missing
and if you're running any sort of
meaningful a sensible uh contextual
banded policy what you'll find is that
places that have higher reward will tend
to be visited more right as and if there
is any sort of continuity between state
and actions and and reward function as a
result of it you kind of see this kind
of piecewise block structure if you
start plotting this data with any sort
of cd algorithm
so the first thing i hope to leave you
with is that matrix completion is is a
lot more rich than just recommendation
systems right it can encode a wide
variety of problems even the top we just
heard you can think of it as a matrix in
some sense
right and so recommendation systems
stagger adoption contextual bandits and
there's a lot more out there
and the goal across these different
applications is to impute the missing
entries that you haven't observed and
the entries that you have observed if
you want to de-noise them because they
might be observed noisily or there's
inherent randomness in how things are
observed so you want to both denoise
observed entries and impute missing
entries
the challenge towards a unified approach
is that different applications induce
very different sparsely patterns that's
really the challenge of of um
trying to think of thinking of all these
various problems to the unified lens of
matrix completion
so here's a formal setup for matrix
completion we'll save an m by n matrix
i'm going to define my expected outcomes
as m and i'm going to define my noisy
outcomes so my random outcomes as y i j
equals to m i j plus epsilon i g epsilon
we're going to take it as mean zero sub
gaussian noise
and the sum binary matrix a which lives
in 0 1 times times n to the n
and if aij is equal to 1 then i observe
it
i observe y i j if aij is equal to 0
then it's missing
and in essence the goal of matrix
completion is given this y tilde and
given a i want to produce an m hat
such that m hat is close to m and some
norm
okay some standard norms that people
think about say would be the frobenius
gnome which is the recovery on average
over all a variety of entries a stronger
norm would say to the infinity norm
where i want to produce a uh entry wise
guarantees for every entry of the matrix
any questions so far about the setup of
matrix completion
okay
and so obviously matrix completion
hasn't studied for a long time the focus
of this talk
is thinking about why data is missing
so why is your matrix of your noisy
potential outcomes your a is your
observed matrix that determines your
missingness and the question that comes
down to is under what conditions
is your y matrix independent of your a
matrix
that's another question we're going to
explore
there are a variety of models of
missingness that have been studied i'm
kind of borrowing this from don rubin
who is at harvard he kind of came up
with this way of thinking about it the
first one is called missing completely
random i'll define these in a second
for short m car
um the second one is a word i've come up
with i'm going to call it literature
missing not at random or lmnor
and these are so far at least in the
literature the majority of models have
been that have been considered fall into
these two categories there's also
something called missing at random which
i call in between these two i'll talk
about it in a second
and the most general model would be mnr
which is missing not at random
and the problem is that um m car and lmr
the the work that's been done so far
does not provide a unified approach to
the variety of sparsely patterns we're
going to look at
okay so here i'm going to borrow a quote
by um ma and chen who are um
at carnegie mellon george chen in
particular
um and so they were a recent paper in
europe 2019 and the last the conclusion
the paper said the following
they said in terms of the theoretical
analysis we've not addressed the full
generality of mnr data and matrix
completion
they say our theory breaks down when the
probability of observation is exactly
zero so for example in the
recommendation system say a vegetarian
may never go to a steakhouse that could
not be dealt with with the models that
have been uh proposed so far for
missingness models
they also assume that we assume that
each entry
is revealed independent of every other
entry
okay so for example in the staggered
adoption setting if i tell you your data
is missing at time t
then you also know that the data is
missing a time keep this one right so
then that condition is no longer cannot
long or
hold and they say these are two open
problems amongst many for robustly
handling mnr data with guarantees right
another one more from the causal lens
perspective is that same contextual
bandits the state actions that are
visited are going to be correlated or
i.e confounded with the expected reward
right and so you have this kind of
correlation structure that needs to be
thought about very carefully
and i know that similar assumptions are
also made by a recent paper by uh
sahabarachary and sort of chatterjee who
at stanford
and by yang ding woo nadel
word cornell
and further note that most the results
that exist for
matrix completion tend to be a recovery
on on average over all the entries of
the matrix so recover in probanious node
right but in a lot of these settings say
in the staggered adoption setting that's
not very meaningful i like to know the
result for just the part of the data
that's missing
ideally what i'd like to know is i'd
like to know entry-wise i'd like to
recover this matrix but that'll be the
strongest notion of recovery
that's very few results exist for
entry-wise recovery
okay so
that's the missingness model matter okay
so i'm trying to make a big huh about it
does it actually matter can i just use
the algorithms that exist so far maybe
they just work as is right so it might
be a theoretical curiosity but
empirically doesn't really make a
difference so let me try to convince you
that that's not the case
okay so here's a very simple example i'm
going to deal with no noise we're just
going to focus on the missingness so
here's a matrix that's 80 by 80. let's
say it's rank 5
um and we have this binary matrix a
i'm going to first create a missing
completely a random
data set out of this well i'll sample
each entry with probability 30
okay so a i j is equal to one with
probability p independent of everything
else in your system
okay that's what i call m car data and
this is kind of the standard model of
missingness that's inside in the
literature starting with candace and tao
no nine candice direct
montanari hasty a lot of a lot of very
influential people have thought about
this problem
uh the second model is lmnr
what when people say lmr what they
really mean is that the propensity with
which an entry is observed can vary
across the different entries so aij is
equal to one with probability pij rather
than p which is constant throughout the
matrix
and this is the model uh of missingness
that's studied by mine chen by the
charlie chatterjee
and then the third model of missingness
is where you can see i'm kind of
breaking the key assumptions of the
first two models so i'm going to say the
minimum probably observing something is
going to be
zero the if i tell you whether one entry
is missing it it informs you about
whether another entry is missing
and the underlying matrix m can be
arbitrarily correlated with a
so you can see at least visually how the
different missing patterns look right
and now we're going to run a very simple
empirical task
so here in light blue is the true
distribution of that 80 by 80 matrix so
it's a 1600 total ratings i'm just
following the distribution between one
to five
in dark blue is the observed m car
samples so this is like approximately 30
of the samples that have been observed
i'm going to distribute i'm going to sam
i'm going to plot the distribution as
well
and the the task at hand is that given
these observed samples kind of recover
the true distribution
okay probably the first thing one should
do when they run matrix completion is
see whether they can do that
and you can see here because the data is
m card the the um up to a normalization
the dark blue looks like the light blue
right they kind of just look like uh
scalings of each other as you would
expect because it's m car data
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is run a method called universal
singular value thresholding usbt which
is a very popular method in the matrix
completion literature it's by paper by
star of chatterjee
at the analysis statistic
and actually it was surprised it didn't
actually work
so
when you try to try to use usvt to
recover the true distribution it just
tends to predict the mean
you can see the difference in scaling
140 to 200.
we try another method which is soft
compute by hd at all which is a very
popular optimization based method and
that works beautifully right you can
look at the dark blue that's recovered
completely covers the light blue as
you'd expect visually it's it's working
really nicely
the third method is a method that we're
going to propose called synthetic
nearest neighbor i'll i'll describe in a
second
uh snn for sure and that also works
quite well right the dark blue is kind
of covering the light blue
so at least with m card data there's an
algorithm that works reasonably well
some methods tend to actually not work
even though they're designed for the m
car case
the next setting is lmr data where now
you can see there's a bias in the in the
observed distribution right it does not
look like m car data anymore there's a
bias in the sampling procedure
and i'm going to try to recover the true
distribution again usvt actually works
uh worse now it just seems to be
predicting the mean right you can see
that it predicts three with
approximately a frequency of 600.
soft impute is working reasonably well
but not nearly as well as it was with m
car data there's clearly a bias you see
that the dark blue that's recovered
um it's not fully covering up the light
blue as you'd hope
right
the last method is snn
we proposed and again works well
now let's move to the last case we're
breaking the assumptions of the methods
so far
um and this is the observed mnr data and
this is the true distribution again
usbt doesn't work unfortunately but what
was our surprise is that by changing the
sampling procedure for the missingness
from lmr data to mnr data soft compute
completely stops working right it was
reasonably predicting the distribution
well now for some reason it just seems
to predict one right
so you can see how sensitive these
methods are to which uh the model i'm
missing this so hopefully i'm convincing
that it is an important thing to think
about
and i wouldn't show it to you if it
didn't work but snn
is recovering the distribution really
well again
and the only reason is because we
thought very carefully about missing
this model which so far matrix
completion hasn't thought about
and so i i hope to convince you that
this is an important problem because
recommendation systems are everywhere
from movies and products and news
articles and with the increasing
polarization of
of the web we should think very
carefully about what is being shown to
whom at what time okay something that's
very important think about
and even things like the u.s census
which is something i've been thinking
about a lot the last past year
approximately 40 of the data is missing
for very sensitive problems like income
and sexuality and things of that form
so and that's clearly not going to be
missing around them right so we need to
think very carefully about why data is
missing
when we
um when we try to use matrix completion
or statistical methods in these kinds of
settings
any questions
yes so on those past slides you're
comparing the histograms of the
predictions versus the truth but that
doesn't really say anything about the
air with the predictions right i was
just trying to visualize it it
corresponds very much to what you see
here like if i plot the forbidden storm
recovery or the
two non-recovering phenomena you'll see
the exact same thing yeah this is just
easier to visualize
so here's the snn method
so those are two ideas one is an idea
from machine learning of nearest
neighbors and the other one is from
econometrics called synthetic controls
so how does nearest neighbor work so say
i want to fill up this entry here which
is a question mark what i do is okay so
what entries have been filled up here
the first column and the
um
fifth column so we look at other rows
that have their first column and fifth
column filled up it turns out the first
row the second row is then we look at
what they filled up for the uh the
fourth column and we just use that to
compute
okay and that's one nearest neighbor you
could prime up with the k nearest
neighbor version of this as well we take
the average of k different things
synthetic controls is a really core idea
in econometrics where um where the
sparsity pattern looks something like
this where you have this little top
slice that's missing the top right sides
uh the canonical example was uh thinking
about
whether prop 99 which is a tax on on
tobacco
um if there had been if that had not
been passed what would cigarette sales
in california have been
and so what they do is they um it's a
very very clever idea um by a body at
all
now it's kind of taking a life on its
own really
and it says okay well the other we know
the other 49 states didn't receive uh
such a an intervention so let's look at
the data before california went under
the intervention i'm going to try to
represent california as some combination
of the other states the different ways
can do this regression originally is
convex regression now there's a variety
of other physical methods have been
thought about from like kernel methods
lasso
we'll talk about the one that we use etc
and so you try to write y1 as some
linear combination of x1
and then you take that beta hat you
learn you apply it to x2 which is the
output the post-intervention outcomes
the remaining states and gives you a
synthetic trajectory of california under
control it's a beautiful two-step
procedure
and synthetic nearest neighbors is
really combining these two ideas and i
kind of think of it as almost like
academic sudoku and i'll tell you what i
mean by that so say there's an entry i j
that i like filled up
what you do is
i'm going to find this matrix x that's
fully filled up with certain properties
in particular the corresponding elements
of it in row i are filled up the
corresponding elements of it in column j
are filled up i call that my anchor
columns and my anchor rows now if you
just look at i j a c x and a r it starts
looking a lot like the synthetic
controls problem right
now the only key trick is that we're
going to divide up x into k different
chunks
okay so i'm going to divide into x 1 to
x k and then i'm going to learn a model
between y 1 and x 1 in particular i'm
going to learn a linear model using
principle component regression so i
first do pca on x1 and then i do
ordinary squares
and i'm going to repeat that process i'm
going to take learn that beta hat apply
it to x tilde 1 to get my first estimate
of m hat i j i'm going to do that k
times for the k different blocks i
created and take the average so you can
think of each of these steps it's kind
of creating a synthetic nearest neighbor
so there may not be another row that
looks like you but something some linear
combination of the other rows looks like
you
okay so i do this k different times take
the average and that's the synthetic
nearest algorithm that's exactly what we
use to produce the simulations uh in a
few slides ago
any questions about the algorithm
yeah why did you break it into many
we're not just a one big block yeah the
reason is that when you're trying to
create entry wise guarantees the k
by averaging okay different things that
gives you a level of denoising implicit
denoising that you would that you
wouldn't get at least you can't
theoretically prove if you just run one
massive regression
yeah exactly that's that's one that's
exactly what's happening in that and
that k is is tuning the bias
so do you have any empirical evidence
that this is better i mean i agree with
you in theory but empirically that this
is better than likely
so it's been mixed so in certain times
we find it uh so we open it this way so
that we found that
if you look at the right of the matrix
if you take the
if each of these things has a rank
that's the the number of singular values
uh is a lot smaller than the ambient
dimension and you do this k different
times the estimate you get from each of
those k things
looks a lot like yes when you get around
the whole thing
and then by averaging that's what helps
you produce these confidence intervals
which at least so you're kind of doing
it k different times you get an
uncertainty estimate
and so consistency-wise we produce the
same thing but i wouldn't know how to
produce a confidence interval if you
just did it with one
yes so something that i like is that to
mention that the way that the
matrix the treatment you observe is
different
can be added to you
yeah that's a great question about how
can you transport this how can you deal
with so when i get to the assumptions
i'll come back to your questions
yes i was thinking
another natural thing to do would be run
something like the media enough means
because you really want consistency not
just like
that might be a good one-sided i think
the median of means maybe you might also
be robust to so like you know what we
are requiring is that these options for
each of those k
parts separately
and so media means might help you deal
with if it only holds for some you know
yeah so
for each
row i column j we uh are we always very
sure about finding out that
big enough x i mean yeah
excellent so uh i'll give three
different answers to that the first is
if you have missing completely a random
data just in the baseline
and with high probability these types of
blocks exist
my second answer is that a lot of the
empirical applications we talked about
like the in econometrics for the
staircase style pattern this people this
is they're almost by definition of the
of the problem
and then the thing is that when we think
about experiment design i'm going to
talk about
um
how to actually so that way you can
actually choose which elements of the
matrix to look at then you can actually
make sure that you have you have it
so those are my three answers
so say for the staircase for example
then do request all the sub x k to be of
the same anchor state and uh for angular
column
you know that actually i don't know
they're just for simplification
is our basic clarification are rows and
columns symmetrical here
but it's some applications is it more
natural to do yes exactly exactly
um how about it take some in a bit uh at
the end of the talk that's right
okay so now let's get to the assumptions
of when does synthetic air sample work
so in general if you have no data you
cannot recover this any sort of matrix
because the number of unknowns is going
to be much larger number of observations
you need some sort of structure in your
data
the fundamental assumption that's always
made in these settings is your data is
low rank or approximately low rank
which basically says that there exists a
latent factor model representation where
the columns can be represented by m
times r parameters and the number of
columns can be represented by n times r
primes
it just is where r is basically a lot
smaller than m and n
now what kind of missingness is allowed
so this is kind of the key thing what
kind of missingness do we allow we allow
for something called selection on latent
factors
okay so what that means is if you look
at assumption one what that implies is
that y i j
is equal to u i comma v j the inner
product plus epsilon ij okay that's what
a large model buys you
what we require is that condition on
these latent factors your treatment
assignment is independent of epsilon
okay the remaining noise in your system
and so these two assumptions together
what they imply is that their potential
outcomes become independent of your
intervention assignments
conditional on you and b
now what does this not allow for
what this doesn't allow for is adaptive
intervention assignments so say i looked
at the matrix i looked at what rating
you got based on what rating you got i
choose the next rating you get then your
intervention assignment is a function of
the previous epsilons and then it's no
longer this breaks down
there are ways to deal with that in
specific cases
but i won't get into that in this talk
at least
so but at the same time this is um it
still allows for things like the
probability of observing an entry can be
exactly zero
that they can be correlated the various
entries of a and m can be
not independent of a
now these are the other operating
assumptions and now i'm going to go back
to your question
the type of assumptions we require are
what we call span inclusions
the two assumptions require is that for
every k
the expectation of x k let's say x one
the the row span of it that includes the
expectation of y
okay so that basically means that you
can represent y as some linear
combination of x one right so that's
what motivates linear regression
now when you transfer your model across
these different interventions as you
were asking what you require is that
this particular expectation of this
thing x tilde one that lies in the
column span of expectation of x one
okay and this this kind of um span
inclusion on the column side is what we
call is kind of a linear algebraic take
on on causal transformability which is
an important topic that people have been
studying nowadays
machine learning yes
you need it for every this is like an
instance based requirement for every ig
and then for every i j if i take my x
and break it up i require for every k
suppose there's also some freedom on
which exactly
yes
so yeah absolutely
yeah what happens if it's like
approximately the stand but not exactly
well the results will kind of pipe
through the same way but with an
approximation error
it just fails with a plus that
approximation
and you can kind of show that if the the
rows of this are sample iid then these
kinds of conditions hold our problem
the last thing you need is because we
assume that every entry is observed
what you require is that the smallest
singular value of the expected matrix
that is much larger than the largest
single value of the noise matrix
given by epsilon
okay so there's the separation of signal
and noise in particular when you plot
when you look at your data of x1 and xk
you should see this kind of elbow show
up if this elbow shows up that means
you're in a that you should use this
kind of method if it doesn't show up
then don't use this kind of method
so it's kind of a you can think of it as
a well conditioning uh well-conditioned
kind of uh condition
yeah and and many people have thought
about these kinds of problems of
separation of signal noise
at least in econometrics uh my earliest
references by chamberlain in 83
and then juan bai and and srina ung and
in 19 by ford canal and many other
people as well
and the last thing requires i'm going to
parameterize the results by how big x is
okay so i'm going to say let's assume x
is the size k cubed by k square i'm
going to create x 1 to x k each of size
k squared by k squared because i'm going
to create k of these blocks each size k
squared by k square i'm going to
parametrize my results in in terms of k
any questions about the assumptions
so given that these are the theoretical
results i can show for
synthetic nearest neighbor
first is finite sample consistency
that is for every pair i j that
satisfies our assumptions the four are
listed above you can show that m hat i j
minus m i j
it scales as this rate where r is the
rank of the matrix m
and k is the number of synthetic nearest
neighbors they have so basic scales is r
3 over 2 divided by square root k
i know it again as someone has asked me
earlier you can prove that k is going to
be growing quick enough
with m car data
and the second thing we can show to
produce confidence intervals is that for
every i j pair that satisfies our
assumptions if you appropriately
normalize it by square root k
and you divide it by the effective
standard deviation i'll talk about how
to estimate this in a second it goes to
a standard normal that's what lets you
produce uh quantify your uncertainty
any questions about the yes
so k is something
so
k cubed like a square something that we
don't decide i'm just assuming that this
exists
if you have a k q by k square how to
break it up i
we decided to bring it up into k case
member k square sub matrices
okay
so the argument is searching for the
lightest text yes
uh but then it uses
x and placing the dot into okay
so
so if you give me a matrix of this size
okay i'm going to divide it up so it
tries to find the matrix of that shape
of maximum size yes i see
okay
the parameter that the algorithm is
doing is if it finds a matrix of this
size we'll break it up into k blocks
how fast is the outputs
how fast is the algorithm
uh so
if this part has been if this matrix has
been found then it's basically doing
linear regression k times for a pca in
an inversion
so whatever your favorite method is for
doing all s and pca that's that time
finding
the optimal
x by itself is a hard problem but
finding approximate versions of it is is
that there exists for algorithms fine
approximations of it
and again you know i think um
there's one perspective is you know
putting like a as a purist which is the
run time and and in terms of actually
finding these optimal matrices like this
a lot of size matrices but actually if
you do this in practice you find these
matrices very easily because your data
is extremely
block structure
it just turns out to be in many
applications
so it's just as an empirical answer
that's that's that's separate as a
critical answer yes
yes i suppose we're going to query this
for many different modes right so is
there like some sort of amortization of
the computational cost that i could do
so that i can run this algorithm
efficiently across many roads yeah so if
you know if it's the same
like you know if you're trying to find
this guy here and this guy's still now
they can use the same x
and we'll talk about this in
experimental design in a second i'll
come back and announce that more
elegantly
okay so let's exactly go back to your
question how would you advertise it
optimally if you could choose which npc
so here's the perspective experiment
design
from the lens of causal matrix
completion
so here's a this connects back to what
was talked about in the slide in the
talk before you know a lot of times when
you go to do drug design you start in
vitro studies and you go towards
clinical trials the individual studies
are extremely inefficient they're slow
rigid take a long time they cost a lot
of money
and there's a high failure rate
so the question is can we identify the
most promising therapies with a very
limited experimental budget
here's one way of thinking about it say
you had m cell types and n different
therapies
i want to recover the outcomes of all m
times n experiments
let's say i only give you a budget of m
plus n experiments to run
which which one should you query
so here's here's a matrix perspective of
it i have m cell types i have n
therapies
which of these entries should i should i
query as you said to amortize best
question
so
this is what you should do you create an
l
okay so if you create an l like this
it's actually the most sample efficient
thing to do
and you can show that you can recover
all the outcomes of all m times n
experiments at an entrywise rate of one
over square root k
by running at most m times k squared
plus n times k cubed experiments
so get these l's when you're writing
experiments
and some interesting questions uh for
the future is like if i had to do the
adaptive setting um how would you design
the experiments and also given this
connections to contextual bandits where
i think of rows and columns as state and
action how do i think about inferences
regret bounds
uh from
of matrix completion those are
interesting things that i've been
thinking about recently
one quick question about that
so this this is optimal given the budget
optimal given the budget yes but uh you
can also show that for any matrix you
can't do any better than endless end
times like r
but if i wanted to optimize given the
objective or given constraints on the
objective then
the optimization is more or my
constraint is on the objective rather
than
the samples
i don't think i've answered
uh can you get better
results in the error in terms of
the questions so you have this
assumption that the minimum singular
vector value of the noise yeah
of your signal has to be
yeah oh yeah totally so so
uh if i have a lot of budget what i'll
do is i'll try to find
um
separate i'll try to create this case of
matrices that's what each of them has
right versus let's say one of them has
the elbow one then doesn't maybe by
permuting the the column the rows in
some way then they both have it because
your error kind of scales with the
minimum uh
single value separation of any of those
matrices so you would kind of keep
trying to find them 35 that elbow in
each
you have all the entries observed plus
noise
so this one does not saturate that
authority no
yeah so there's a square root
uh that's uh
all right
um i'll go very quickly to the
heterosynthetic variance estimation
so in particular to produce those
confidence intervals uh i need to
estimate the second moment of epsilon
which i write as sigma square i j
uh in general you know if the variance
could be different across the ijs and so
how would you estimate these things
which is crucial to produce the
confidence intervals
well we're going to use a usual trick is
that let's assume the sigma square ij is
a low rank as well
if that's the case then what can you do
well first note
that if i take an entry-wise squaring of
each entry y
right um in expectation it's m square i
j plus sigma square i j
so let's define um
sigma and s as the as the as these two
matrices
then you can prove that the rank of s
of this matrix
is bounded above by the square of the
rank of your original matrix m
plus the rank of your sigma matrix
right so if your m is low rank and your
variances are if you're if your first
moment is low rank of m and the second
moment is epsilon is no rank
then this entry-wise squaring is also
going to be low rank
and so here's an estimator so first i do
is i take my original data y
with the missing values i apply
synthetic nearest neighbors to it to get
m hat i j
then i do an entry y squaring of each
entry and apply synthetic nearest
neighbors again
and because an expectation it's m square
i j plus sigma squared j that's exactly
it'll produce a good estimate for that
and then if i want to produce sigma
square i j i take what value i got here
and i subtract it from the square of
this guy
right now i have an estimate for the
variance
right and this is the meta algorithm it
doesn't even need to be for synthetic
ignorance never you could replace this
with nuclear non-minimization whatever
you want right it's just like a meta
algorithm two-step way to compute
heteroskedastic variances which is the
important problem in statistics
econometrics
okay so the power structure guarantees
you can show us that your scale
basically has the maximum error of these
two things
because you're using the rank structure
you don't even care about how the
numbers are represented suppose i scaled
a bunch of rows
a bunch of columns by a different amount
feels like it it's completely
or it doesn't care about like the
scaling up
i guess that's maybe my question yeah
like would it affect so suppose i
represented some
entry using different units
but the guarantees depend on that or
yeah so while
units in which
you're measuring things
okay the last uh okay so the the kind of
the philosophical message
of the review with this five talk
entrance is many times called a missing
data problem and matrix completion for
those of us do that is called a missing
data problem and there's a lot of
beautiful mappings between these two
things so in causal inference you have a
question of a causal estimate
that can be thought of as
recovering a matrix in a certain norm
um in causal infancy of what we call
compounded data that really amounts to
having missing not at random data
in causal inference you have different
kinds of observational experimental
studies that really amounts to having
different kinds of sparsely patterns in
matrix completion
and the goal of causal inference is to
estimate potential outcomes and the goal
of matrix completion is to impute
missing entries and they kind of have
this one-to-one mapping between these
two things which i really like seeing
okay in the next five minutes i'll give
you a very quick tour of the things i'm
thinking about nowadays which is of uh
causal offline rl and i'll try to
connect it with what we just talked
about
so what at least i find interesting
about rl when i think about what is
behind some of the most popular
achievements in rl
it's the ability to ask questions and
answer questions on the following form
which is what if some agent took some
action at a given state
and the simulator basically gives you as
an article for these kinds of questions
okay so if you think about say and to me
this is a causal question
so if you think of board games and video
games where you have like your atari and
elf and you go you have the simulator
for free right the rules of the board
game basically give you an answer to
this kind of
question and the otherwise what you do
is you build these really complicated
simulators physical simulators of your
system say in robotics
what i believe is a challenge to the
widespread use of rl is building such
simulators for more complex engineering
and social systems
and i know that simulators are also
abundant in in very core engineering
systems say in robotics we talked about
in network simulators like where we
think about queueing models for for
latency so a very typical one that
people use as ns3
in in circuits people use something
called spice so people have handcrafted
these simulators to come up and think
about their algorithms
and as i said because these engineering
systems are getting increasingly complex
and we're starting to integrate them
with social systems we can't always
simulate a system at will let's me come
up with alternate methods to do that
the question is can we build causal
simulators for rl using historical data
what i mean by that is where you have
offline data we just get say state
action say reward
uh
trajectory per patient you can't
experiment with your system
and it's observational data
so what i mean by that is for those of
you who study these kinds of systems in
an mdp let's say a pomdp and a partially
observed markov decision process
the state transition can be a function
of a latent factor that you don't see
but your action is a function of
observed observed state
right and what makes this problem harder
what i called causal rl is where the
action itself has a latent factor going
into it and i call it a latent
confounder
this is what makes it harder than a palm
gp
and so here's a
um something more on the empirical side
of work we've done on it uh and this is
with collaborators at
mit
so i'll just do a very quick uh run
through of it
so here we took one a very simple uh
system from openai which is a
um
the open air gym where people try out
different rl algorithms the first one
you go there is something called
mountain car which is a non-linear
control problem we want to take this car
up to the top of a hill
right and it's under power so you can't
just drive it all the way to the top you
got to keep going left and right left
and right to build momentum and then you
get to the top of the car to the top
okay so the state in this case the car's
position velocity the actions are going
left right or doing nothing
and then you can have different um um
environments so i can one thing in tune
in the open ai gym is the gravity of the
system or the mass of the car
equivalently
and under different levels of gravity
you have different optimal policies
right so if you have very weak gravity
and it's not unpowered you can just go
right
if your moderate gravity you want to go
left and right for you want to keep
going uh you want to go left first to
create enough momentum and then you can
just go right and with strong gravity
then you have to go left and right
repeatedly to create enough momentum
like a yoyo
and if you run like a different dqn
policies on open ai it kind of reflects
what i'm saying in english
and
if you had such a simulator right for
for getting this thing up for getting
this thing up the hill you can keep
trying in the simulator as much as you
want and then using model predictive
control or deep qn you can get at the
top of the hill
and so what i call online rl for those
of you not familiar is where you have
access to the simulator and you can
experiment with your system
in offline rl you don't have access to
the simulator you just have access to
limited historical data and it could be
observational data which makes it even
harder right so the question is can we
build a simulator for mountain car using
just one observational trajectory for a
car okay that's the question we're going
to talk about
and here's a tensor completion
perspective about it
so again
rows are states columns are actions each
entry here that's in yellow is an
observed state action transition that's
seen for that particular curve and
what's missing is that state action
tuple has not been seen and the entry
here is going to be the next state okay
rather than means reward is going to be
the next state
and if you have n different cars then it
creates this tensor right with different
entries being seen in the different
slices of the sensor and because the
cars have different masses any policy
you learn to use to to drive the system
will observe different things based on
the latent confounder which is the mass
of the car
so you have mnr data because your state
action that's visited and the next state
that comes out is a function of the mass
that's a latent contaminant
and it turns out that if you think of
this problem through a low rank uh
tensor which is the kind of a the higher
dimensional analog of low rank matrices
you can have this tensor factor model
we have a factor for action the fact of
the car the fact of the state
and using a neural network you can kind
of learn these low dimensional latent
factors
and what persim does is comes up with an
architecture using this perspective of
inspiration of tensor completion with m
data using a non-linear factor model
and the latent factors that actually
learn cannot be very meaningful so if
you look at the mountain car example
it's kind of a 2d pro 2d projection of
the learn latin factor of the car it
really corresponds really well with the
true gravity of that car
or the mass of that car we applied it
for other settings say in uh in the half
cheetah which is the more complex system
again the two-dimensional latent factor
that's learned from the for the cheetah
turns out to be correspond really nicely
with the true mass of the cheetah and so
and so forth so these latent factors
really turn out to be quite meaningful
and it's it's a it's a good way of
thinking about this problem
and so this is the last slide so here
i'm comparing it with a state-of-the-art
method called cadm which is
context-aware
dynamic model which also learns
simulators but does it with offline with
online data
and um i'm going to run a simulator for
you so here's what persim does in dark
grey is what is learned and true in the
true is what actually is happening so
you want them to be really close to each
other and persim is doing it really well
and because the data is offline and it's
confounded you can see cadm is mistaken
so to end um i guess my my takeaway
message for you all is engineering and
or needs causal inference for modern
decision making
and um particularly to bridge these two
fields and causal and matrix sensor
completion is an effective framework to
pose these questions and to design
arguments
okay these are some references
and with that i thank you very much
[Applause]
uh so there's a lot of questions during
the talk just to keep this on time
yes